et l'histoire de l'exclavage devrait
être enseignée par tous dès 2006 avec la
réactualisation des manuels scolaires
comme l'a indiqué hier soir le premier
ministre
il faut dire que le souvenir de ces
pages d'histoire est très inégale en
france très présent aux antilles il
existe à peine en guyane département
pourtant directement marqués par
l'eclavage une date de commémoration
face à une histoire encore en friche
l'esclavagé sujet tabou en guyane les
faits peuvent le laisser penser
a contrario des antilles qui multipliait
lieu de mémoire ici quasiment rien à
cayenne hormis la statue de chez cheikh
pas d'autres monument rendant hommage
aux esclaves à leurs souffrances à leur
combat pour la liberté dans le rapport
du comité pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
un volet consacré au rôle central de
l'école l'esclavagé dans les manuels
scolaires une montagne à gravir deux
professeurs d'histoire et d'une
historienne s'ils sont attaqués et un
manuel d'histoire et de géographie
entièrement dj la guyenne
vous allez retrouver par exemple
l'origine
des esclaves la traite vous allez aussi
trouvé la vie sur les habitations le
marronnage bien sûr c'est à dire la
recherche de la liberté et
l'abolition de l'esclavagé mais l'école
n'est pas le seul ex de la commémoration
la protection et la mise en valeur des
lieux historiques est considérée comme
une priorité
l'habitation beauregard compter en 1833
près de 40 hectares de canne à sucre
plus de 45 esclave
ainsi si riche qu'il suffit de se
baisser pour trouver des vestiges d'une
grande valeur historique
un lieu investi par des agriculteurs qui
chaque jour détruisent ce qu pour être
sauvegardés